round six of more things you didn't know
about breath of the wild
this time we're gonna dip our toes again
into more secrets about the game's
development and game files
so if you continue to enjoy this series
support us by liking this video
it helps a bunch and here we go
[Music]
it's possible to make a pet guardian
that keeps returning to you
in a previous video i showed how to
disable a guardian using urbosa's fury
and stasis
but a side effect of this is if they get
pushed or launched away
they will always return to the point
that got disabled which means you can
launch them using cryonis
and have them walk back to you like a
dog and if you wanted to launch over
with them
and go for a quick ride
this is different from the old guardian
riding technique because this is
actually a friendly guardian
who's a good boy most skyward sword fans
saw this hard to misreference at the
spring of power when breath of the wild
first released but there's another
skyward sword reference that is not so
obvious
the wall designs on skyloft's walls are
seen at lenairu promenade
all old and worn down while it's
completely impractical to do the fact
that you can
launch an item stasis the next object it
hits
transfer that momentum then repeat onto
the next object
just shows how cool breath of the wild's
engine really is
and a testament to how well it works
there are two enemies in the game that
don't break your weapon when you throw a
weapon at them
malicize can be destroyed when you throw
a weapon at them and bees are
immediately dispersed when you do the
same
it's even considered a critical hit
on the same note there's also a
technique called unbroken throw that
allows you to throw against enemies
without breaking your weapon
by first striking an object before it
touches the enemy the weapon doesn't
break
the easiest way to do this is with the
master cycle now you can throw freely
without worrying about losing your
weapon
you can headshot stall enemies even when
their bones are still a pile in the
ground
did you know that all explosive barrels
are not created equal
where some barrels did massive damage
while others only stung a bit
that's because there's actually three
different damage values for explosive
barrels
including the additional fire damage
weaker barrels do 10 damage
middle barrels do 46 damage and strong
barrels do a whopping 86 damage
unfortunately there's no way to tell
them apart visually so here's a map of
the different damaged barrels
specific style coblins have some really
strange properties when they die
instead of falling apart they slowly
float up to heaven
there is one deciduous tree aka non-pine
tree that exists in snowy areas
this single tree south of north lomay
labyrinth it even grows
out of solid bedrock weird while swift
carrots may seem plentiful and easy to
get because of kakariko village
this is actually one of the rarest wild
ingredients in the game with only a
handful of them on satori mountain
and a singular carrot someone dropped
behind the horses at the highland stable
did you know that moblins can throw the
barrels you can hide in
there are many places throughout the
game that block horses from entering
called horse barriers most of these have
a roof though so if you can drop down on
them from above with your horse
you can walk around on thin air
normally rocks have a random chance to
drop loot under them
but several rocks in hyrule are hard
coated to give you specific drop table
rewards every time
such as ruby only rocks or only rocks
and special ones such as this rock as a
tory mountain which always gives you a
diamond
and this rock in front of the old man
which always gives you a high tail
lizard which was likely designed to
teach and reward
new players to pick up rocks which
normally would be a low chance at random
rewards
there's a mysterious asset named air
wall for e3
still in the game's file originally
designed to keep players out from
accessing certain areas in the breath of
the wild e3 2016 demo
strange thing is that this same asset is
still used in the game but is barely
ever seen
with almost all of them with collisions
set to false so link simply walks
through this invisible barrier but there
are some
e3 air walls that still work such as the
holes you shoot through as sheem the
ghost shrine
and the wall surrounding the great
plateau tower to prevent you from
falling too far away from the tower
bottom
did you know that the wolf link amiibo
helps you search for items you pinged on
your radar
when nearby a searched item it will head
towards it and wait for you to pick it
up
on the same note if you search for a
rusty broadsword here at the gerudo
canyon pass
it says it's nearby but nothing is found
it seems like it would pair well with a
single rusty shield on top of this rock
and it does if you decide to clip into
the rock below the rusty sword is hidden
inside
sitting on top of the stone below breath
of the wild has a certain type of rocky
terrain that you've definitely seen
before as a barrier or a cliffside but
what you might not know is what its
official name is
the official asset name by nintendo for
these rocks are
cliff cheese wall cliff cheese stone and
cliff cheese rock
now i'm hungry there is one apple near
the horwell bridge that's buried
underground
barely noticeable but did you know that
round bombs are thrown farther than
square bombs
the fastest way to gain a horse's trust
is by spurring quickly
breaking then soothing then accelerating
again
literally speed running a horse's
friendship
if you headshot this moblin in hyrule
castle while it's on the stairs
he'll uh go for a little ride
i remember doing that when i was a kid
there is some secret dialogue you will
never see
unless you went out of your way to
reload certain conversations
such as with barda during the search for
barda quest where the conversation will
be completely different if you have
gerudo armor
on or off did you know you could protect
yourself against thorns with deruk's
protection without actually cracking the
shield
this might seem straightforward for some
players but most players still don't
know that you can simply switch runes
through the rune explanation menu
[Music]
did you know that the hp scanning system
used to be an ability that the sheikah
slate would always have
you used to be able to scan enemies from
a distance and display their hp
just like the champion's tunic or
ancient armor in hindsight i'm glad
they went with the armor idea because
running around and scanning enemies
doesn't really sound fun
when disarmed style zoflows like to
attack just like any other
zolfos empty-handed by tail whips or
tongue attacks
except it has no tongue or guts so when
it tries to
nothing happens it's trying its best
this is what breath of the wild's map
looked like back in 2014
and this is what it looks like now it
might not be so obvious
in normal gameplay because once enemies
see you they don't really care about
anything else and simply attack you
but most enemies such as moblins lost
and bokoblins are actually terrified of
guardians
there are a ton of things in the game
that can be parried but did you know
that you can parry a fire chuchu jelly
while ice and shock jellies aren't
blockable fire jelly's explosions are
actually considered a strike
and can be parried the guardian
skywatcher's weak spot is a sheika
symbol right on its top
the interesting thing though is that the
guardian turrets strewn around hyrule
castle are all just
upside down skywatchers with these weak
spots protected since they're right side
up
but if you clip underground you can just
one shot them from underneath by
exploiting the same weakness
and that's a wrap hopefully you learned
something new again today to show off to
your friends
if you like this series and more
breakdowns check out our breath of the
wild expert series playlist
and of course for everything else gaming
stay tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
you